the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
alright my friends in this video i have
some very interesting information that i
want to share with you the first thing i
want to say is if this information is
indeed accurate game of thrones would
have had a very different ending if the
show's writers would have followed
through with this as you all know game
of thrones had arguably one of the most
divisive endings in all of television
history the final season of game of
thrones gave us several different major
events that shocked millions of fans
around the world one of those major
events was when arya stark
single-handedly defeated the night king
with her valyrian steel dagger in
winterfell's godswood well according to
someone who once worked on the show with
maisie williams they said that moment
should have never happened at all
because arya stark should have died in
season 7. on the most recent episode of
dak shepard's show the armchair expert
ed sheeran revealed that season seven of
game of thrones should have been the
last season for our beloved arya stark
now according to ed sheeran the main
reason why he was brought onto the show
for his one and only scene was because
it was meant to be a farewell gift for
maisie williams season 7 was initially
gonna be her final season on the show it
sounds as if the game of thrones writers
dan and dave were gonna get rid of arya
before the final season let me show you
what he said so you can hear it for
yourself
here's my question wait we never figured
out why
how was it was a surprise she was
obsessed with you no well not obsesses
maisie had come to shows so i'd met her
she came in dublin i think because they
were filming in belfast so i'd met
maisie probably when she was like
12 maybe maybe 13. she's always been
awesome and i don't think they've
written the ending yet or it was meant
to be like her last season but it wasn't
and they said as a surprise for her
because it was her last season they
would get me on so she was meant to turn
up on set and i was by the fire and she
was meant to know her lines and
everything get down and be like oh how
um
yeah but
it was it was great it was great
now i think this is fascinating
information because of the effect it
could have had on the ending of game of
thrones if arya stark would have died in
season 7 then that obviously means she
would not have been around to defeat the
night king herself that makes me wonder
if david and dan did get rid of arya
earlier who would have stopped the night
king during the long night battle in
winterfell for those of you who don't
know the show's writers have went on
record and said that they did not like
the idea of jon snow killing the night
king
hopefully you forget about the fact that
arya stark ran out of that castle with
the battle drums playing and going
towards some purpose and we don't know
what until it happens we hope to kind of
avoid the expected and jon snow has
always been the hero the one who's in
the savior but it
just didn't seem right to us for this
for this moment we knew it had to be
valyrian steel
now if it wasn't arya or even jon then
who would have delivered that fatal blow
this also makes me wonder if arya stark
would have in fact died in season 7 how
would they have done it if you remember
at the beginning of season 7 we see arya
stark wiping out most of house frey
before she makes her way up to
winterfell where she would spend the
rest of the season i do wonder where and
how she would have died do any of you
think she would have died somewhere
around the scene where she reunited with
her direwolf nymeria maybe she could
have died immediately after leaving
house frey or shortly after seeing
nymeria again
or would she have died in winterfell
when littlefinger was setting her up to
go against her sister sansa maybe they
would have had lady brienne kill arya in
order to save her from killing sansa or
maybe they would have sent arya
somewhere else now if you remember she
was on her way to crossing cersei's name
off her list before she found out jon
and sansa had retaken winterfell from
the boltons she only went home because
the starks had retaken wonderful again
but if it wasn't for that she would have
went right to king's landing instead i
thought you'd be in the winterfell
why would i go there the boltons have it
no the bottoms are dead
what
jon snow came down from castle black of
a wilderness battle of the bastards
he's king of the north now
maybe dan and dave had another idea in
mind maybe they would have had her go to
king's landing for cersei but somehow
she could have died before she made it
out of that city honestly who really
knows but it is interesting to know that
arya was initially set up to die in
season 7. as you all know this certainly
would have affected the way the show
ended we never would have seen her and
gendry take their relationship one step
further although i am sure some fans
would have liked that more
we're probably going to die soon
i ought to know what it's like before
that happens
we also would have never seen her
reunite with john the hound melisandre
or any of the other amazing characters
she met along the way we obviously would
not have seen her defeat the night king
and we also would not have seen her set
sail for what lied west of westeros
either let me know what all of you think
about this new information do any of you
think this means that arya will now die
in the books this might have been
something else george rr martin gave
them only they decided to go in another
direction for whatever reason this
certainly opens up a lot of different
options also do any of you think ed
sheeran misunderstood why he was
actually there or do you think arya was
really meant to die in season seven and
if so how do you think arya would have
died and who do you think would have
been the one to kill the night king my
money is still on jon snow although dan
and dave had said they did not want jon
fighting the night king
leave me some of your thoughts down
below i want to know what all of you
have to say about this one
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching the video i
hope you have a great day i will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you